that we just went on holiday yeah on a
ski trip which uh we've revealed is not
going to be a special yeah unfortunately
we do like to hang out with each other
and uh not always have god
we hang out outside of context outside
even though joey joey made a little bit
of
which watermelon
or may not not be out by now i'll
probably probably be out by now yeah but
uh we went to
uh where did we go again you said koi
it's okay
that's a that's a monster that's a manga
i i completely just i the [ __ ]
one of the most famous ski resorts in
japan probably like top two is it the
most famous oh hakuman niska the two
famous ones oh yeah that's true the two
big boys
not that famous though yeah zelda is
famous in japan i've also been there and
is like very very old yeah it's it's
it's not as great every ski lift is like
a plank
it's just like took yeah i mean hand
crank i mean i would say that this is my
first proper ski trip because unlike
before i only went for a day and then i
was like out of commission for like
every other day so i had like one day of
snowboarding this time i had basically
like four days of snowboarding two like
full hard days and two like kind of like
softer take it easy days still four days
of snowboarding and uh yeah it was a lot
of [ __ ] fun yeah but my god did my
body hurt the day after holy [ __ ] did
your mum ask you how the white person
sport was
so she asked you last time yeah she
asked me last time
i will say though i will say
it was so weird going to that ski resort
and just going to that town and just
seeing more people speaking english than
they were japanese i think i heard less
japanese like i heard more chinese and
english than i did japanese oh yeah yeah
and that's only going to increase once
the board open up yeah yeah yeah because
like every single staff member not just
in the hotel we stayed at but just in
town for some reason spoken english i
spoke english and you know there are a
lot of a lot of aussies there a lot of
waterfalls yeah um and you know if the
if they weren't speaking english then
they were basically speaking you know uh
mandarin or cantonese you know and then
you had the very few people just
speaking japanese the japanese people
were literally in the minority yeah from
what i could see and the country's
closed off so how bad is it going to be
when the country actually opens up and
tourism comes back in because yeah
because i remember because i remember
when i worked in uh hakuba which is the
other famous one niigata that is like
it's like almost 99 percent
uh it's like 99
australians
like it's actually it's actually scary
like i remember some days being there
like going around to like restaurants
and stuff yeah and i would step outside
after the restaurant and i'd be like oh
yeah i'm in japan
because when you're inside the
restaurant everyone's australian yeah so
it feels like i'm back home in australia
it feels like every country has their
their national pests yeah
australia has the cane toads
so you know when you're at home
oh my god no because yeah it was it was
super surreal for me being in a place
which was you know very clearly japan
but you know all the signs were in
english the menus were in english um and
all the staff members spoke english as
well weird man it was weird like i tried
my best to speak japanese to like anyone
i met you know whenever i went to a
cashier or something and anytime i did
they would just always reply back in
perfect english
that's funny because when i was booking
the
hotel i booked the hotel for us all
right
i i but i booked it right i asked like
for like a shuttle service
to pick us up because it's like two
hours two hours and a half yep yeah from
the airport
yeah and i was like well there's you
know on booking.com it says they have a
shuttle service oh great great so i
clicked it two days before they uh they
messaged me they're like by the way we
don't have a shuttle service and i was
like
what
what do you mean you know shuttle
service they're like i have one but we
can help you get one you just go to
these links and get the bus yeah and so
i go and look for the bus there's no
seats left on the bus i'm like oh [ __ ]
what do we do yeah so i call up the
hotel and then i remember so this is
where i i talked to the guy and i'm like
i'm like oh is english okay in japanese
and he's like in english he goes oh
thank god
that's great that's perfect
i was like yeah i don't really like
speaking japanese
he's like from the philippines
okay i was like all right i'm sick and
he was like super chilly yeah yeah we'll
get you a taxi mate you'll be all right
yeah
very expensive taxi oh my god
[ __ ] up we didn't book beforehand yeah
like normal people because we we booked
the
trip pretty late as well right we're
like two weeks before yeah yeah so it's
like quite expensive but it was good
though but like it's like a smack bang
in the middle of the season as well so
it's probably like the most amount of
people but it was really good
very good i would say this was like
probably the coldest weather i've
consistently been in because like
throughout my entire life like the
coldest weather i've really had to deal
with is like
minus five minus six right oh my god
okay so how did you manage huh how did
you manage so like so like in my mind
when you guys were telling me to pack
winter clothes pack all these different
kind of like you know
thermal gear and everything like that
i'm just like it's cold i get it i know
i'm going to i know it's going to be
cold
nothing in my mind could process really
just how cold it is up there and just
how cold it feels because to me
like it gets to minus five and anything
below minus five i'm just like
[ __ ] it's cold i'm like
i know mother it is cold you know that's
how my mind processes it yeah but i
didn't like my body wasn't prepared for
just like the different types of
coldness because it just never had
experienced that before at least like
not too not to such a big degree because
i've been in you know wisconsin in
winter and it gets [ __ ] cold in there
but we just stay inside all the time
we're not out there [ __ ] snowboarding
skiing
yeah to put in perspective i think every
day on average it was like minus like 10
or 11. it was yeah it was minus like 16
at the top as well yeah yeah yeah it was
more
like shot down even lower yeah like
because you'd wear like this um i don't
know what you call it not a battle club
but like just like a cloth
like a like a face mask
well it's just like a piece of cloth
that you put underneath your mask that
blocks here so you don't freeze your
face off yeah but like the one of the
days was so cold that like after like
one run of going down like one of the
things
i tried to touch it and it was rock
solid yeah like it like really moved
it's just like frozen yeah it's crazy
it's so cool though man there's such a
such a cool ski resort it was i i guess
being in that kind of cold weather or
being that in that kind of cold place
kind of put things into perspective for
me
with that if you are like ill-equipped
like just to go outside for like a quick
walk or something you'll probably die
yeah
and i guess i've never been in an
environment where i've needed to
worry about just having basic gear to
protect myself from the weather
otherwise my life would be in danger you
know what i mean yeah and i yeah like it
gets cold but it's like bearable yeah it
gets cold but like just runs in there
it's combing in it just once in there as
tesco's and just you warm up you you run
a bit more but like um and here's the
company was like 30 minutes yeah yeah
because there's not there was nothing
right and i remember when we arrived
when we arrived to the hotel we got
greeted by the receptionist and
everything like that and he said oh you
know um if you want to go into town
make sure you book a taxi because if you
don't book a taxi every taxi is going to
stop at about midnight
and they've had some people that have
gone into town which is a bit further
away from the ski resorts and had no way
to get back in like minus minus 10
weather it's like a 20-minute drive it's
like a 20-minute drive yeah it's like
it's like a two-hour walk yeah yeah yeah
yeah the ski resort has a bunch of uh
different areas around it yeah
yeah we went we went to this village
called hirafu which is technically on
the next mountain over that just puts
into perspective how far away that is
yeah so it just made me think [ __ ] man
if if we just forgot to call a taxi one
day we'd just be [ __ ] because nowhere
would be open we can be we can we can
get home and we just have to like
survive outside in the wilderness and
like minus 10 minus
10 degree weather celsius by the way
celsius went to that one bar and was
he's australian or south african i think
it was australian uh no no no he was
dutch i believe was he really yeah oh i
think his account was he touched him his
accent sounded like i thought he had a
nausea this this guy was just like he
was just like we're like what do we do
if we miss the cabs i would know if he
was also
okay
okay he definitely wasn't an aussie he
was he was european we asked him we're
like what do we do if we miss the cabs
and the guy's like oh just walk home no
he said no he was like where are you
staying and i was like uh at the at xyz
hotel it's like it's walkable
and i looked at the google maps it was
like an hour and 40 minutes an hour and
40 minutes i'm like
it's certainly walkable
would i do it though
in -15 degree weather is a different
question
i mean
walkable is a technicality i can yeah
i'm sure a human would be able to walk
from one end to the other i mean
hokkaido to tokyo is walkable
like you can walk it if you would want
to i mean the south pole is walkable
people have done it if you're jesus you
can walk anywhere
the pacific isn't warm
i have legs
oh my god